Another thing that's alarming to me is the redefining of terms like sexism and
racism or sexism against men.
It's impossible.
Racism against White People's impossible,
right?
This redefining as these prejudices only exist if you're coming from a position
of power.
That's really weird.
And it also,
it opens up the door to treating people as an other,
literally the people that are the victims of racism are now using racism against
other people and feeling justified because of it and it,
and having a bunch of people that will agree with them that this is in fact not
racism.
And this is pushing back on white privilege and saying all these different weird
things that you know,
and,
and they feel really comfortable in saying these open,
racist,
generalizing things about white people or about white men or about,
you know,
fill in the blank.
But whatever group that you're a,
you're attacking and it's,
it's really strange.
It's really strange to see.
But again,
it makes sense if you look at the different games.
Yeah.
So if you're on university and you think you're playing the truth game and
philosophers are great at this,
they're always unpacking terms.
And so you might try to define racism ever or any sort of ism and you a common
sense view.
It would be an expression of hostility or resentment or limitation on a group
based on their identity.
Um,
but that's if you're playing the truth seeking game,
if you're playing the politics game or the warfare game,
um,
you want to define the terms to give your side maximum advantage.
So there's a wonderful social psychologist named Phil Tetlock at Penn,
at Wharton,
and,
and he talks about these different mindsets we get into.
And one of them,
he calls the intuitive prosecutor.
So if,
if I'm,
if my goal as a scholar is to prosecute my enemies and maximally convict them
and I am always trying to defend,
you know,
seven different identity groups against the straight white men,
they're the,
they're the accused.
I want to define my terms to make it maximally easy to convict.
And so I am going to say racism and microaggressions.
It doesn't matter what the intent was,
all that matters is the impact.
All that matters about the person felt that way.
As long as someone's offended,
I get to charge you with a crime.
So,
uh,
and also on racism,
um,
you can say as,
as you know,
a lot of kids are learning in high school that these days racism is prejudice
plus power.
So by definition a black person or a gay person or whatever and he cannot be
racist or whatever other term because they don't have power regardless of their
social class actually being taught.
Yeah.
So their professors are,
this is coming out of their mouth.
Well just saying,
so this is taught in a number of high schools,
uh,
at my nephews went to Andover,
they learned this offensive thing.
It'd be teaching children.
It's not just that it's offensive and obviously hypocritical.
It's that it's crippling.
Yes.
I mean you imagine,
can you,
so look,
you've got,
you've got kids,
right?
You have two,
two daughters and three cause you have three daughters.
Can you imagine giving your daughter's a cloak of invulnerability where you say
you put this on now you get to attack others,
but no one can touch you.
Like this is going to warp their development,
power corrupts and even moral,
a rhetorical power corrupts as well.
How is this being taught though?
I mean how,
how is this becomes accepted as a part of a curriculum?
So,
um,
because the goal is not truth,
the goal is victory over racism let's say.
And so if that's the case,
you're going to focus on educating kids about their white privilege and um,
making end.
So that's what a lot of these privilege exercises are.
You line kids up by their privilege and you and your,
your goal is to make the,
the straight white boys feel bad about their privilege and therefore talk less,
take up less space,
their privilege.
This is what we were talking about earlier about the goal is no racism.
The privilege only exists if there's racism.
Like instead of concentrating on the privilege that it only exists if people do
preferentially treat certain,
the preferential treatment towards certain races.
If that doesn't exist at all,
then white privilege doesn't exist.
Well,
I'm actually,
I'm not sure I'd agree with you on that.
So we have also,
well,
so we had a funny episode last night and so my wife and I were out in La.
We were invited to the Golden Globes by,
by a friend.
And so we're here in la.
So we,
we,
um,
uh,
we go to bed in the hotel room and at two in the morning,
the guys pounding on the door saying,
come on,
let me in.
It's me,
it's me.
And you know,
I wake up and I go to the door and I,
and I say,
wrong room and he can't hear me.
So I opened the door a crack and to show him,
you know,
like,
look,
I don't know,
I don't know who you are and you know,
some drunk,
some drunk guy.
And uh,
and I said,
you know,
you've got the wrong room.
And I went back to bed and breakfast this morning.
My wife says,
why didn't you open the door?
Like,
how could you have done that?
I said,
you know,
we're in a nice hotel.
I mean what's,
you know,
what's going to happen?
And she made it clear like a woman would never have done that.
Like you as a man,
you have the ability to go out in the world and engage with in a certain way
that I don't have as one.
I,
that's a great example.
So there is a kind of male privilege.
Sure exists.
Even if there's no sexism.
Yeah,
that's an interesting,
that's an interesting example.
Um,
that's a,
that's a sexism one,
but that's also a physical danger one.
Yeah,
that's it.
There's a,
there is a difference between just the way women have to go out into the world
being vulnerable and also being the target of,
of just a male sexual attention.
A very different thing.
It's an aggressive person.
Dangerous thing.
Yeah.
But I,
I think you could say the same thing about race in this way.
So,
um,
cause there's racism though.
Well,
okay.
Okay.
You're right.
If,
if there was absolute zero racism anywhere,
but whenever going to get to that.
But,
but the thing that we're worried about is the racism.
So like if you worried if someone's,
if
you say you have white privilege,
well that only exists if you are being dealt with in a racist manner.
So if you're a black person and there is racism that's being directed towards
you and it's not being direct towards me,
then you can say,
well I have white privilege,
but if there's no racism directed towards anybody,
that doesn't exist anymore.
So the issue is racism.
Yes.
Right.
Okay.
But so look,
I think it's,
it's helpful to always try to look at it from the other person's point of view.
I want to listen to their arguments and stuff.
For example,
when you and I go into any social encounter,
it never occurs to me that something,
you know,
something's going to come up and someone's going to call me a Kike,
let's say.
Right?
Yeah.
Cause I'm,
I'm Jewish and it just,
it just never crosses my mind that someone's going to humiliate me because I'm
Jewish.
Um,
um,
but if you're black,
even if you're in a very tolerant society,
at some point someone is going to make an assumption,
it might not be.
It might be.
So all I'm saying is you and I don't,
there are certain things we don't have to think about and that whereas if we
were black or other identities or visibly gay or you know,
there would be the risk of spoiling of a social interaction.
So I'm totally comfortable saying we should be telling our kids about this,
but what follows from it?
What follows from it?
Should we therefore be telling kids?
Okay,
so you know,
um,
you know,
judge people based on their appearance,
um,
be suspicious of people based on their race and gender.
That's where,
that's where I get off the bus,
the bus.
That's where I say,
now we're really hurting kids.
We should be turning down the moralism and we're turning it up.
Right?
But what I'm getting at is pointing at someone and saying,
you have white privilege.
If they are not racist,
you're,
you're giving this person,
you're putting these PR,
this person in a category that really only exists in the face of racism where
the real problem is racism.
Yes.
With the male female thing is a very different way.
That male privilege I think is way more slippery and wave cause it's
biologically based.
There's a creepiness to men and then there is as much as a nice guy as I'm sure
you are,
and I try very hard to be a nice guy.
No,
just kidding.
But every woman's encountered creeps.
Yes.
It's inevitable because it's,
there's a,
a game being played this pursuing of sexual pleasure or of,
of,
of sexual encounters.
This doesn't exist or it shouldn't exist with races.
Yeah.
The just the,
the real problem in my eyes is racism and if we could figure out a way to just
complete,
obviously it's not going to let people are flawed.
They're,
they're going to be,
until there's some sort of new way that we interface with each other that
eliminates lies and deception and allows each other to completely understand
each other's feelings and appreciate them,
which may happen some day,
probably technologically driven until that happens,
there's going to be a certain amount of it,
but the real enemy is racism.
It's not white people just getting lucky.
Yeah.
Okay.
But I would say not that we shouldn't acknowledge it.
Yeah.
So you,
you said earlier about how definitions change.
So we are evolving as a society.
We're getting less sexist and racist and so our threshold for what counts as
sexist and racist going down,
that's a good thing that should happen.
Right?
Um,
but I think what we need to call attention to is that when you,
if you lower the threshold faster than the reality changes,
then you make progress.
But yet people feel worse and worse.
And so,
um,
and so I think that's part of what's happening on campus.
That makes sense.
The,
the progress.
So the,
the,
the loudest protest tend to happen at the most progressive schools.
It's places like Middlebury.
And Yale and Berkeley.
Um,
and you know,
so I think that we are,
we are,
if you bring in a diverse student body and we're all trying to diversify,
we're all in.
Every school I know of is trying very hard to create a very diverse student
body.
So if we do that and we bring people in and we give them a common humanity
approach,
it's going to work great.
Diversity.
If you handle it well,
it can confirm many benefits,
but if you handle it wrong,
if you try to make people see race and other groups more and you attach moral
valence as to it and you give them a lot of the stuff that they get in the
grievance studies,
of course they're going to be angry and of course they're going to feel that
people hate them.
It's a terrible thing to bring people into a university and to teach them,
you know what this institution is white supremacist people have implicit bias
against you.
Wherever you go,
people are going to hate you.
Like,
no,
this is a really bad thing to do to create an open,
trusting,
inclusive,
diverse environment.
Right?
The right thing to do would be to emphasize how foolish racism really is and
about how damaging it is,
not just to our culture,
but to you as an individual to look at people in that way and not open your
heart and your mind to all these different races.
And I think one of the worst examples of modern racism that's gone on checked is
what's going on at Harvard with Asian students or Asian students are instead of,
instead of being completely neutral in terms of how they approach all these
races,
Asian students actually have to try harder to get into Harvard and there because
there's so many of them and they're doing so well,
they're being punished for excelling,
which is really racist.
It's racist against the people that are doing the best,
which is really crazy.
And there are minority,
which is even more crazy.
And because of their culture,
because they're so hard working and they're not in general than the not the type
to be really loud and protests these things.
Right.
It's gone on and he targeted to the point where now they've had to have a class
action lawsuit.